this is the closest to outside they can
get
for the next five days no going to work
no running out to get groceries police
swarmed nine public housing towers in
melbourne on saturday evening
blocking driveways and doorways to
prevent anyone from leaving
it isn't a crime scene the state
government says is to avoid an explosive
coronavirus outbreak
there's 27 confirmed cases of the virus
among the 3 000 residents of the estates
the the nine towers that are being
locked down
will be locked down for at least five
days
because that is deemed the appropriate
period to test
everybody every single resident other
than those who've already tested
positive
across those towers the authorities
insist the lockdown isn't about
punishment
but protection except some residents say
they're being treated like prisoners
aid groups have expressed concerns about
vulnerable communities inside the units
some who have fled war or family
violence
they are calling for less police
officers and more social workers and
translators
i don't for a moment underestimate how
challenging
uh how traumatic in some respects that
will be for those
3 000 residents the state government has
offered a two-week rent freeze
and welfare payments to support those in
the lockdown
but residents say the seriousness of the
measures are unfair
with many highlighting how other people
in locked-down suburbs
are still allowed to leave their houses
for work or grocery shopping
their tenants feel powerless they will
spend the next five days waiting for a
knock at the door
that brings food supplies or a covid19
test
and won't be allowed out until everyone
has been
they're in a tested the quarantine
officially started at noon
but residents got an extra few hours to
return to their homes
from now on no one is allowed to travel
to or leave the city of jada
and its surrounding communities in the
west except to go to work
the measures have been met with
understanding from residents
i hope that the lockdown is effective
and the outbreak is contained
so that we can quickly return to normal
life
if the outbreak is here then it's better
to lock down only one area
rather than the whole region
instead of a complete lockdown where
people are confined to their homes
authorities are focusing on travel
restrictions and preparing hospitals in
the affected region for the search in
covet 19 cases
we believe that we have to take specific
measures in liaida to protect the most
vulnerable
people to reinforce protection in our
health centers
and in the hospital itself
most of the recent infections were
reportedly recorded in retirement homes
a residential area and on farms
in april the ada issued an urgent call
for workers for its surrounding farmland
but migrants eager to make money in
times of crisis
exceeded seasonal demand
the result a large amount of poor
unemployed workers
sleeping on the streets in cramped
apartments
or in makeshift government shelters the
risk of infection among them is high
health authorities are also afraid of
them spreading the virus when they move
to a different area to look for work
that's why from tuesday workers entering
or leaving the zone
will have to present a certificate from
their employer
the first visit to the pub in more than
three months
the reopening is taking place amid
strict measures
which even royalty have to observe
prince william got his first drink in a
day early
ordinary citizens had to wait till
saturday morning for the pubs to open in
england and northern ireland the british
government fears there could be a mad
rush to the drinking establishments
the health minister warned his
compatriots not to mess things up
saying those who get carried away could
be jailed
prime minister boris johnson also called
on britons
to act responsibly
all these businesses and their workers
have put in a heroic effort
to prepare their venues for this
reopening
to work out a way to trade that keeps
their customers safe
but the success of these businesses the
livelihoods of those who
rely on them and ultimately the economic
health of the whole country
is dependent on every single one of us
acting responsibly restrictions have
been used for other businesses as well
including hairdressers museums cinemas
and restaurants
critics say the reopening comes too soon
currently there are around 500 new
infections a day
but the numbers could soon spike again
like they did during an outbreak in
leicester
earlier this week the city of 300 000
residents in the heart of england is
still under a local lockdown
and the government has warned that it
will not hesitate to order the closure
of businesses again
if there is a fresh coronavirus outbreak
well let's bring in our correspondent
charlotte potts who is standing by
outside one of those pubs in
london charlotte the uk is the european
country worst hit by the pandemic
from where you stand does it seem like
brits are really ready to go to the pub
again
oh yes they are i actually witnessed
that myself today
i'm in a neighborhood in south london
and all the pubs and restaurants are
really really full here especially
younger folks
we're very excited to return to the pubs
they've now waited over
three months and this pub that you see
behind me for example is taking
the temperature of its guests and
clients when they
come in to get a beer but that seems to
be
about all the measures they are actually
taking there is
zero social distancing inside or outside
the pubs the streets are crowded
people are talking to each other
in different group settings i mean
the british really love their pubs and
they are excited
to be back on the streets but again um
very little
social distancing going on here and that
is why scientists
also warned that there could be a second
wave of infections and that it was way
too early to open
the pubs here again as you mentioned
restaurants and
hairdressers also open today but for
example
theaters and gyms are
remaining closed at the moment and
people are asking
why can pups open that are such a huge
horde of infection when theaters have to
remain closed at this point
well let's talk about that and the
bigger picture in general what do people
make of their government's handling of
the coronavirus crisis
well at the moment there are over a
hundred people each day still dying from
the virus and the pandemic has hit
the uk extremely hard and a lot of
people blame that
on the prime minister boris johnson's
handling of the crisis on the
government's
crisis management boris johnson's
approval ratings are now way down
brits are saying that he locked down the
country
too late um and now they are worried
that the track and trace system which
should keep this pandemic the virus in
check is not yet in place
but indeed everything is opening up so
very big worries here
in the uk of a second wave of infections
at the moment
all right charlotte potts in london
thank you so much
you